[Musik]
von
ja,
ich würde behaupten, dass das, wovor die Wähler insbesondere
hier bei dieser Wahl Angst haben,
was die Republikaner in
Iowa antreibt, die Angst vor weiteren vier
Jahren eines demokratischen Präsidenten ist,
was sie letztendlich am meisten wollen, über
jedes bestimmte Thema hinaus  Sich dem
Land oder der Welt zu stellen, bedeutet zu gewinnen.
Sie wollen sicherstellen, dass sie
den Kandidaten nominieren, der Joe
Biden im November schlagen kann, und dass das über
alles andere hinausgeht, über jedes Thema, über das wir
mit Wählern sprechen, die zweitrangig sind, um
Cathy gewinnen zu wollen  Der Experte ist hier in Iowa.
Covich ist der Chefredakteur hier in Iowa. Der
Kapitalversand ist
gemeinnützig, also Cath. Cathy, Sie wissen
tatsächlich so viel über den
Iowa-
Caucus.
Kathy. Natürlich müssen wir zuerst erklären, was die
Caucus-Veranstaltungen sind. Ja, die Iowa-
Caucus-Veranstaltungen sind also sehr alt  Eine Möglichkeit für
Nachbarn, sich zusammenzuschließen und
Entscheidungen für ihre politischen
Parteien zu treffen. Der Caucus in Iowa ist eine
Veranstaltung zur Präsidentschaftsnominierung. Die Veranstaltung geht
auf das Jahr
1972 zurück, als die nationale demokratische
Partei und die staatliche demokratische Partei
die Präsidentschaftsnominierung durchführen wollten  Der
Prozess ist integrativer, um
mehr Stimmen einzubringen, die über die
Parteibosse und eine Art Elite, äh,
Demokraten hinausgehen. Deshalb haben sie dieses System entwickelt,
bei dem die Leute persönlich zu
Bezirksversammlungen gehen, sie könnten in einem
Schulhaus, einer Feuerwehrwache oder einem
Rathaus sein, ähm  Und und treffen Sie sich und
stimmen Sie darüber ab, wen Sie als
Ihren Präsidentschaftskandidaten haben möchten. ähm, Iowa
wurde landesweit Erster, weil die
Wahlversammlungen eine Reihe von
Kongressen einläuten, es gibt einen ähm, einen
Bezirkskongress und einen
Bezirkskongress des Staatskongresses  Bis zum
Nationalkonvent und ähm, damals
in den 1970er Jahren dauerte es lange, den
gesamten Papierkram auszudrucken. Sie hatten
einen alten Mographen bei der
Demokratischen Partei von Iowa. Es dauerte lange, den
gesamten Papierkram zu drucken, und so wurde ihnen
klar  ähm, dass sie, indem sie sich darauf stützten,
wann die Wahlversammlungen stattfinden müssten, um
all diesen
Konventionen gerecht zu werden, am Ende die
Ersten in dem
Land sein würden, von dem Sie sagten, 1972, was eigentlich
der Tag des Datums damals war  Damals, als es
so kalt war wie heute
hier
[Musik]
Milwaukee ähm
hier
ja, Kathy, wir haben Fragezeichen in unseren
Augen. Ich meine, die große Frage ist, wie kann
das sein, dass die Leute auf eine Art und Weise wie diese
entscheiden können?  Wir haben so großen
Einfluss darauf, wer der Kandidat sein wird,
weil wir das Gefühl haben,
dass derjenige, der hier zuerst reinkommt,
vielleicht der Kandidat auf dem
Weg ist, die Nominierung zu gewinnen, aber wer auch immer
Zweiter ist, ist knapp Zweiter oder etwas, das
im nächsten Jahr alles verändern kann  Ein paar
Wochen, also wie ist es möglich, dass
Iowa so mächtig ist? Ja, was wir
über die Wahlversammlungen in Iowa gerne sagen, ist nicht, dass
sie die Ersten sind, weil sie wichtig sind, sondern dass
sie wichtig sind, weil sie die Ersten sind,
also wissen Sie das  Ist das Wahljahr noch
sehr früh im Jahr? Das ist das
erste Mal, dass echte Menschen im Gegensatz
zu Umfragen
jetzt rausgehen und ihre Stimme abgeben, wenn man sich die
Geschichte der Wahlversammlungen in Iowa anschaut
Wählen Sie normalerweise nicht den
Kandidaten oder den Präsidenten, von dem Sie wissen, dass das
hin und wieder vorkommt, ähm, es passierte
mit Jimmy Carter, es passierte mit
Barack Obama, ähm, George W. Bush gewann die
Wahlversammlungen und wurde später der
Präsident, den Sie kennen, also gibt es da ein paar
Beispiele, aber  Es ist nicht
unbedingt die Norm, ähm, was Iowa
zuverlässiger tut, ist zu entscheiden, wer nicht
Präsident wird, ähm, und damit meine ich, äh,
wir haben dieses Jahr mit über einem
Dutzend Kandidaten begonnen, ähm, es sind noch ein
halbes Dutzend übrig, also das hier  Der Prozess, bei dem
man versucht, in
diesem Fall auf der republikanischen Seite einen sehr
konservativen Teil der
Republikanischen Partei anzusprechen, erweist sich
für einige dieser Kandidaten als zu viel
und vielleicht etwas Geld, ähm, aber
sie wissen, dass sie merken, dass sie
keinen Anklang finden und sie
aussteigen. Mai springt da rein und ich versuche es
auf Deutsch zu erklären, also
ähm, ähm,
Florida regieren,
das war gestern faszinierend, Cathy ähm,
wie Anna gerade gezeigt hat
Als wir gestern auf der Disantis-
Veranstaltung waren, trafen wir Leute aus Florida, darunter auch einige
Staatsvertreter, die hierher kamen, um
für Ron Disantis zu werben. Aber das
Interessante ist, dass Ron Disantis,
der als sehr ernsthafter
Kandidat begann, vielleicht der einzige ist
Wer könnte Donald Trump um die
Nominierung herausfordern und plötzlich ist er
hier in Iowa vielleicht sogar auf Platz drei,
wie ist das passiert? Rhonda
Santos ist, ähm, er kandidiert sozusagen als
die nächste Generation von Donald Trump, ähm, das
war er, glaube ich  Er baute auf der Idee, dass die
Wähler denken würden, dass Donald Trump zu
alt sei, ähm, dass seine rechtlichen Probleme vielleicht
seine Fähigkeit,
für das Präsidentenamt zu kandidieren, beeinträchtigen würden, ähm, und ich glaube,
DeSantis war sich zu diesem Zeitpunkt nicht wirklich bewusst,
dass er immer noch gegen ihn antreten würde
Donald Trump, ähm, er hat
Donald Trump während des gesamten
Wahlkampfs nicht kritisiert, ähm, er tritt im Grunde nur
als eine Art „Nächste Generation“ an, um
Donald Trumps Politik fortzusetzen, und
da Donald Trump immer noch im Rennen ist,
funktioniert das bei den Wählern nicht und so und
so  Denken Sie, dass Sie, äh, Sie, Rhonda
Santz, ähm,
er hat eine Menge seiner äh, er hat
sozusagen alle seine Eier in den Iowa-
Korb gelegt, er hat sehr, äh
stark auf die Vorwahlen in Iowa gesetzt, und es ist eine
große Frage, woher er kommt
Hier geht es ihm in New Hampshire nicht sehr gut.
South Carolina ist Nikki
Haleys Heimatstaat und bis dahin
könnte die Nominierung feststehen. Bleiben wir noch
einen Moment bei Rond Zantes, also Kathy,
er war in allen Landkreisen hier in Iowa
und Tred, um seine zu machen  Pech, ähm, was
würde also passieren, wenn er
hier tatsächlich Dritter wird und vielleicht
auch in New Hampshire Dritter wird? Nun, ich weiß noch einmal,
ich denke, das wird von seinen
Spendern abhängen. Sie wissen, dass seine Spender diejenigen sind,
die entscheiden, wie lange  Diese
Kampagne geht weiter, wie lange sie
seine Kampagne noch finanzieren werden. Ich
möchte jedoch sagen, dass Ronda Santis
trotz der Umfragen, die wir gerade sehen,
eine Chance hat, immer noch
Zweiter zu werden, und der Grund, warum ich das sage,
ist, dass ähm  Die Umfrage für Nikki
Haley zeigt, dass ihr Bericht ziemlich
weich ist, ähm, in dem Sinne, dass die Leute
von allen Spitzenkandidaten am wenigsten begeistert sind,
ähm, und dass sie immer noch sagen,
dass ihr Verstand es sein könnte oder dass sie
immer noch überredet werden könnten, für jemanden zu stimmen
Sonst haben sowohl Donald Trump als auch
Ronda Sandz einen viel höheren
Prozentsatz an Wählern, die sich
entschieden haben, dass sie sich mit Sicherheit
für die anderen Kandidaten zusammenschließen werden, also ähm
und das Dritte ist, dass Ronda Santz
eine viel bessere Basis hat
Organisation, ähm, das macht Nikki Haley zu diesem
Zeitpunkt, ähm, viele Freiwillige, ähm,
Bezirksleiter, Leute, die, ähm, Sie wissen, dass sie
Leute anrufen werden, um Hilfe zu bekommen,
sie zu den Wahlversammlungen zu bringen, und dass
das bei dem kalten Wetter
auch wirklich so ist  wirklich
wichtig,
Nina
von
ähm, ich habe erlebt, wie Leute mir gesagt haben, dass
Nikki Haley die beste Wahl sein könnte,
weil sie grundsätzlich wählbarer ist, also sind sie
nicht so enthusiastisch
Und es heißt, dass die Hälfte von
Nikki Haleys Unterstützern
Unabhängige oder Demokraten sind, sie sind keine
Republikaner, und Sie kennen die Leute, mit denen
ich gesprochen habe, darunter ähm, wissen Sie, die
Leute in der Stadt würden mir sagen,
dass sie vielleicht gehen, als würden sie normalerweise
Versammlungen abhalten  Demokraten, aber sie könnten sich
für Nikki Haley entscheiden, weil sie
Angst vor Donald Trump haben. Sie
haben Angst vor
Donald Trump und denken, dass Nikki
Haley die bessere Wahl wäre, aber nicht,
dass sie sie wirklich nicht mögen  dass sie
im November für sie stimmen würden, aber äh,
aber sie haben Angst vor Donald Trump,
das müssen wir erklären, weil es
verrückt klingt, dass dies die Republikaner-Fraktion ist,
die an diesem Montag stattfindet, und dennoch
könnten
in dieser Fraktion Demokraten und Unabhängigkeitsparteien abstimmen  Ich
bin Demokrat, also warum ist das möglich, warum liegt
es nicht in der Nähe von Independence and
Democrats, also war es schon immer möglich, dass
Leute zu den Wahlversammlungen gehen und
ihre Parteiregistrierung ändern können, um
teilzunehmen, und dann wieder wechseln, ähm, und
so gibt es immer Sie  Kennen Sie
die Gelegenheit, insbesondere für politische
Unabhängige, die möglicherweise immer
Republikaner wählen. Sie wissen, dass sie
aus irgendeinem Grund politische Unabhängige sind,
und das gibt ihnen die
Möglichkeit, sich zu beteiligen  Am
selben Abend wie die
Republikaner, so dass die Demokraten
sozusagen in ihrem eigenen Haus bleiben, gehen sie hin
und treffen sich mit den Demokraten. Dieser
Zyklus ist anders. Die Demokraten ähm, es wird
Wahlversammlungen geben, aber es wird nur
Parteiangelegenheiten sein, es wird keine
Präferenzabstimmung für den Präsidenten sein  und diese
Präferenzabstimmung des Präsidenten findet in
diesem SU-Zyklus als Briefwahl statt,
und die Ergebnisse werden
erst im März bekannt gegeben,
dem Super-Dienstag, wie wir ihn nennen. Es
gibt also nicht wirklich einen Wettbewerb,
mit dem man konkurriert  die Republikaner
und daher besteht die Möglichkeit, dass es
mehr Demokraten und mehr äh,
linksgerichtete Unabhängige geben könnte, die sich
entscheiden könnten, aufzutauchen und im Wesentlichen
gegen Donald Trump zu stimmen.
Jo [
Musik]
unabhängig
[Musik]
für
Kathy haben wir mit jungen Leuten und ihnen gesprochen  Er
sagte, zwei Dinge: Erstens
wären die Republikaner viel besser dran,
eine jüngere Generation als
Kandidaten für Disantis oder Haley zu haben, denn das
würde die Demokraten so stark unter
Druck setzen, einen 81-Jährigen loszuwerden, der
für das Präsidentenamt kandidiert,
und zweitens wäre das so  Sie
denken auch, dass dieses Land einen
Generationswechsel in seinen
[Musik-]
Themen braucht, also brauchen sie Kandidaten der jüngeren Generation,
um ihre
Themen vorzubringen, und sowohl Nikki Haley als auch Ron
Santis und einige der anderen Kandidaten
haben im Wesentlichen argumentiert, dass sie
subtil sind  Darüber sagen sie nicht unbedingt,
dass Donald Trump
zu alt ist, um Präsident zu sein, aber Nikki
Haley hat tatsächlich vorgeschlagen, dass es einen
Kompetenztest für
Spitzenbeamte der Regierung geben sollte, wenn sie über 75 Jahre alt sind
Die
Tatsache, dass eine weitere, jüngere
Generation dieses Land verlassen muss,
ist jedoch sehr wichtig, wenn man sich
die Umfragen ansieht,
bei denen
Donald Trump
bei jüngeren Wählern gewinnt  Und
wenn wir zum Beispiel über das Wetter
und die Begeisterung sprechen, ist das ein
weiterer Vorteil, den er hat, weil
jüngere Wähler
bei schlechtem Wetter eher rausgehen
als die sehr alten Wähler, wie es Kathy getan hat  „
Got
Caucuses“
ist
für mich so, als wäre ich eigentlich wirklich
überrascht, nicht überrascht, aber es ist
erstaunlich, wie alt die Leute im
amerikanischen Politiksystem sind. Gibt es eine
Erklärung, die man dem deutschen Publikum geben könnte? Ein
Teil davon liegt meiner Meinung nach an der
Macht der Amtsinhaber, also äh  Schauen Sie sich äh,
schauen Sie sich Iowa an, äh, unser Senior-
Senator ist jetzt der am längsten amtierende
Senator von uns, äh, er ist äh, fast 90 äh,
und er dient schon seit
weit über 40 Jahren, äh, äh, bevor wir
auftauchten  Hier trafen wir unseren ehemaligen Gouverneur
von Iowa. Er war
unglaublich lange im Amt und der am längsten amtierende
Gouverneur in der Geschichte der Vereinigten
Staaten. Okay, also die Iowaner im
Besonderen und ich glaube, die Amtsinhaber. Ich meine, ich
denke, die Amerikaner im Allgemeinen
wählen jemanden  Und dann fühlen sie sich
bei ihnen wohl, äh, sie machen keine Lust,
etwas zu ändern, und äh, das ist das
politische System, äh, es hat nur wirklich
viele Vorteile für Zuwanderer, sie sind
besser in der Lage, Geld zu sammeln, äh, sie haben, äh,
wissen Sie, eine Menge davon
Möglichkeiten, ihre Botschaft zu
verbreiten, die die Herausforderer einfach nicht haben, und
ich denke, dass
diese Dinge zur Langlebigkeit dieser
ähm dieser Kandidaten beitragen,
ganz gleich, ob Iowa eine Amtszeit hat oder nicht, die
USA haben eine Amtszeit  Grenze für Präsidenten,
sie können nur zwei vierjährige Amtszeiten absolvieren, ähm.
Donald Trump wird das natürlich nicht tun, würde
nicht vier aufeinanderfolgende
Amtszeiten absolvieren, ähm, aber äh, wissen Sie, er hat erst
später in seinem
Leben
für die Community von
YouTube kandidiert  Kathy, wir haben unsere Community auf
YouTube gebeten, uns tatsächlich ein paar Fragen zu schicken,
und sie haben gut gefragt, was
das Alter angeht. Ich meine, Joe Biden ist 81
Jahre alt und dieser Benutzer hier
denkt offenbar, dass er geistig nicht in der Lage ist,
Präsident zu sein, warum sind wir das?  Wir
berichten nicht auf eine Art und Weise darüber, wie er es von
uns erwarten würde, weil er sagt,
das sei etwas anderes, als wenn wir beispielsweise Donald Trump behandeln würden
Konservative Medien nähren diese
Wahrnehmung, dass er irgendwie nicht
kompetent ist, ähm, und dennoch
veröffentlicht er seine medizinischen Berichte, wie es die meisten
Präsidenten tun, ähm, wissen Sie. Ich denke,
dass es einfach nicht viele
Beweise gibt, die das, was die Leute denken, stützen
Sie wissen, und Sie wissen, wie sie sich fühlen, wenn sie ähm,
Sie sehen sich die
Rede von Präsident Biden an,
manchmal ähm, und er gab vor einiger
Zeit zu, dass er tatsächlich eine Sprachbehinderung hatte,
ähm, und deshalb
ist seine Rede manchmal nicht so  glatt, ähm, oder er scheint den
Gedankengang zu verlieren, während er
versucht, ein Wort auszusprechen oder
an ein anderes Wort zu denken, ähm, also ich denke,
dass das diese
Wahrnehmung beeinflusst, aber ähm, wenn man sich die
Medien anschaut, ist der Republikaner  Partei und
Leute, die konservativ sind, konsumieren ähm,
dieses Narrativ ist sehr stark, ähm, aber
es basiert einfach nicht wirklich auf vielen
Beweisen, also schaffen sie dieses Bild von
Joe Biden, okay, denn ja, ähm,
Jo, der auf
seine physische Erscheinung wartet, scheint
zerbrechlich zu sein  Dieses Bild scheint alles außer Kraft zu setzen,
so dass wir auf Leute stoßen, die
sagen, er sei geistig nicht fähig,
was anscheinend nicht wahr ist, weil wir
aus unserer Erfahrung wissen, dass er
alles im Griff hat, aber er wird es in
diesem Wahlzyklus schwer haben  Ich schätze,
Wahrnehmungen sind sehr wichtig, ähm, und
oft, ähm,
wählen die Leute ihren Kandidaten auf der Grundlage der
Stimmung aus, die sie empfinden, der
Emotion, die der Kandidat beim
Wähler auslöst, und nicht auf
wirklich allem, worauf sie basiert  Intellekt, also ähm,
Sie sprechen oft über die
Sympathie eines Kandidaten, ähm, und das ist
im Grunde genommen ein Gefühl, das der Wähler
gegenüber einem Kandidaten hat, und das hat nicht
unbedingt etwas damit zu tun,
was er tun wird  Amt oder
was ihre Fähigkeiten sind, ist nur eine
Frage, und Sie wissen, ich denke, einer der
Gründe, warum Donald Trump in Iowa so erfolgreich war, war, dass er
als Berühmtheit begann. Die Leute hatten das
Gefühl, ihn zu kennen, ähm, sie
dachten, er sei lustig und
unterhaltsam, ähm  Und das gefiel ihnen
an ihm, und als er
anfing, für das Amt des Präsidenten zu kandidieren, zog er ein
riesiges Publikum an, bevor
irgendjemand wirklich wusste, was
seine Absichten waren, weil sie das
Gefühl hatten, ihn bereits zu kennen,
Donal
trp New
Yorker Essen ist
verständlicher, aber als wir vor ein paar Tagen in Leyon waren,
ähm, das ist einer der
ärmsten Landkreise oder liegt in einem der
ärmsten Landkreise
in diesem Landkreis. Ich meine, sie haben
Barack Obama gewählt oder für ihn gestimmt
28 und 12 und dann haben sie
für Donald Trump gestimmt. Ich meine, wie ist das
möglich, dass sie wechseln?
die
von Barack Obama zu ähm zu ähm
zu Donald Trump wechselten ähm. Ich denke, dass sie
Hillary Clinton nicht mochten, ähm, vielleicht sogar
mehr als sie Donald Trump mochten,
dass sie eine sehr polarisierende
Kandidatin war, ähm, Sie wissen, dass Sie
die Idee des Wollens betrachten  Jemand Neues, ähm,
wissen Sie, wir hatten gerade ähm, Sie wissen,
Rücken an Rücken, fast Rücken an Rücken, ähm,
Büsche, ähm, im Weißen Haus, ähm, wissen Sie,
jetzt gehen wir zurück zu den Clintons, ähm, die Leute hatten das
Gefühl, sie wollten jemanden neuen
ähm im Weißen Haus sehen  Und ich denke, Sie
wissen, dass Brock Brock Obama auf
jeden Fall etwas
Neues darstellte, ähm, aber jetzt, wenn Sie zum Jahr 2016 kommen, ist es
Donald Trump, der das Neue war,
Obama
Donald, also frage ich mich, Kathy Donald
Trump  Als er vier Jahre lang im Amt war,
hat er für
die Menschen in den armen Landkreisen in
Iowa und
anderswo nicht viel bewirkt, aber jetzt unterstützen sie ihn
erneut, und Sie wundern sich, dass wir
jetzt einen Präsidenten haben und darüber berichten
Angesichts all dieser Investitionen in
die Wirtschaft scheint es der Wirtschaft
ziemlich gut zu gehen, es wurden Arbeitsplätze geschaffen,
das Durchschnittseinkommen ist höher als es
jetzt tatsächlich war, ähm, als vor
der Pandemie, und trotzdem dringt es nicht
zu den Menschen durch  sind
unzufrieden, unzufrieden mit Joe Biden.
Ja, das ist eine sehr nationalisierte
Wahl, ähm, das wird immer mehr, und
so, ähm, wissen Sie, die Sichtweise der Menschen
in Iowa zum Beispiel ähm wird
von den Medien und dem, was
sie sehen, beeinflusst  Land, ähm, Sie wissen, dass
wir hier in Iowa eine Gouverneurin haben, die eine
Republikanerin ist. Sie hat gerade ihre
Botschaft über die Lage des Staates übermittelt und darüber gesprochen,
wie großartig die Wirtschaft in
Iowa ist und wie niedrig die Arbeitslosigkeit ist, und
wir haben ein großes Budget  Überschuss, damit wir es uns
leisten können, weitere Steuersenkungen vorzunehmen. Ich meine,
das ist die Botschaft, die sie
von ihrem Gouverneur, ihrem republikanischen
Gouverneur, bekommen, und dennoch schauen sie immer noch auf die
Volkswirtschaft und sagen, dass die Inflation
zu hoch ist, wissen Sie, die Biden hat
Äh, hat die Wirtschaft ins Chaos gestürzt,
diese beiden Dinge sind einfach nicht
miteinander vereinbar, ähm, aber Sie wissen ja,
sie werden von dem, was sie
im Fernsehen sehen, und diesen Nachrichten beeinflusst, und
anscheinend stimmt das nicht, denn
natürlich ist die Inflation immer noch hoch, aber  Es ist
viel niedriger als vor einem oder zwei
Jahren. Ja, die Leute spüren es nicht,
aber ich meine, die Inflation ist, wie Sie wissen,
gesunken, ähm, aber es ist nicht Null. Die
Inflation ist immer noch viel
niedriger, als sie war, aber die Preise
steigen immer noch, und wenn die Inflation sinkt,
sind die Preise nicht gesunken, also
gehen die Leute zum Lebensmittelladen und denken immer noch,
dass sie zu viel
für Milch bezahlen, sie zahlen zu viel für
die Staples oder wissen Sie  Man geht in ein
Restaurant und die Rechnung ist viel höher
als ähm schon vor der Pandemie,
und deshalb haben die Leute immer noch diesen
Schmerzfaktor, dass sie immer noch das Gefühl haben,
die Auswirkungen der Inflation zu spüren, obwohl sich
die Wirtschaft insgesamt sehr erholt hat
Sehr
gut,
wenn wir uns ansehen, was in
diesem Jahr passieren wird, ist das hier erst der Anfang der
Wahlversammlungen, es werden also wahrscheinlich noch
ein paar Wochen vergehen, bis wir wissen, wer
der Kandidat in der
Republikanischen Partei sein wird. Wir scheinen zu wissen, wer wer und wer  Ich
werde auch der Kandidat der
Demokratischen Partei sein. Was ist Ihre
Prognose, was
im November passieren wird, wenn
Trump gegen Biden das Ticket ist?
Ähm, Trump schneidet
heute in den Umfragen besser ab als Biden, ähm, aber der
Präsident, das Rennen um die Präsidentschaft, ähm, ist
nicht, ähm, es ist keine nationale Wahl, es ist
eine Reihe von Wahlen auf Schlachtfeldern,
ähm, und Sie wissen, es ist
letztendlich ein Wahlkampf, ähm, ähm,
wissen Sie  Donald Trump, wissen Sie, Joe
Biden, ähm, könnte ähm sehr gut
ähm die Volksabstimmung gewinnen und trotzdem die
Wahl verlieren oder umgekehrt, also
sagen uns Umfragen nicht wirklich viel, wissen Sie, ich
denke, ähm, letztendlich wird es darauf ankommen,
ähm  Was passiert mit der
Wirtschaft, äh, was passiert, äh, mit der
Südgrenze, ähm, die Leute sind
hier sehr besorgt über die Grenzsicherheit, ähm,
und ich denke auch, dass, ähm, es
darauf ankommt, ob es Trump gegen Biden ist,
ähm, die Wahrnehmung der Menschen davon,
wer gesund ist  Genug und von wem kann man
wissen, dass er tatsächlich vier Jahre lang Präsident ist?
Donald
ist
[Musik]
für [
Musik]
für
[Musik],
ja,
die Newans und die Deutschen, die wir haben,
und daher kommt das Wort,
das in den USA verwendet wird. Die Angst
Deutsche Angst, wie Sie es hier in den
USA nennen, wir haben auch diese Angst und das
Unbekannte, was im November passieren wird
und was passiert oder was
passieren wird, wenn Donald Trump
zurückkommt und wieder ins Amt kommt, was
bedeutet das für Europa und die NATO?  Beispiel,
aber auch, was es für die
amerikanische Demokratie bedeutet, weil wir so
viel über einen autoritären Zug
innerhalb des Trump-Teams hören.
Das
halbe Land hat Angst vor all
den Dingen, die Sie gerade über
Donald Trump gesagt haben. Ich meine, wie wird er die
amerikanischen Beziehungen in der Welt verwalten? Wird
er aus der NATO austreten? Wissen Sie, wie
wird er mit diesem Krieg umgehen?  In der Ukraine,
ähm, sagt er natürlich, dass es
in der Ukraine keinen Krieg gegeben hätte, wenn er Präsident gewesen wäre. Nun,
Sie wissen, ich weiß es
nicht, ich weiß nicht, ähm, Sie können das nicht auf die eine oder
andere Weise beweisen, das ist nur einer von beiden
Dinge, die er sagt, ähm, Sie wissen, was
mit Ihnen passieren wird. Wenn
es um die nächste Wahl geht, wird es
eine nächste Wahl geben oder wird Donald
Trump sie aussetzen, damit er wieder im Amt sein kann,
ähm, ich meine, denken Sie an all diese
Dinge  Äh, sind äh Dinge, vor denen Leute, die
nicht für Trump sind, Angst haben. Es
gibt eine ganze Reihe anderer Ängste für
Leute, die für Trump sind, äh, einschließlich
Sie wissen, werden wir das
gesamte Geld in unserem Haushalt ausgeben, äh, helfen
Sie beim Einschenken  Geld in die Ukraine und äh,
Israel und Taiwan, ähm, wenn wir
es eigentlich ausgeben sollten, ähm, Menschen
davon abzuhalten, über unsere Südgrenze zu kommen, ähm,
wissen Sie, wir haben Angst vor Kriminalität, wir haben
Angst, äh, äh, dass die Demokraten
kommen und unsere Waffen nehmen  Weg,
wissen Sie, also all diese Ängste, ähm,
und aufgrund der Polarisierung
sind die Menschen geteilter Meinung darüber, welche Ängste
sie haben sollten, Sie wissen, dass sie
handeln sollten.
Ich muss mit einer Frage fortfahren:
Müssen wir uns Sorgen um den Amerikaner machen?
Demokratie Ich denke, viele Menschen machen sich
Sorgen um die amerikanische Demokratie. Ich
meine, ich meine die Anstrengungen, die unternommen wurden, um
die Ergebnisse der Wahlen von 2020 zu kippen,
bis hin zu einem Angriff auf
die US-Hauptstadt am Tag, an dem die
Wahlen stattfinden sollten  Seien Sie versichert,
das ist sehr besorgniserregend, ähm, Sie wissen, dass
das Wahlsystem untergraben wird
und die Zweifel der Menschen,
dass die Wahlen fair und
unparteiisch sind, zunehmen, ähm, all diese Dinge,
einschließlich Sie wissen, sogar unser ähm, unser
republikanischer Außenminister hier in
Iowa  Wer ist der Administrator
der Wahlen im Staat? Er hat
Bedenken geäußert, dass Menschen
die Integrität der Wahlen untergraben, aber
Verschwörungen, Fehlinformationen und
Desinformationen nutzen, also gibt es eine Menge Grund zur
Sorge. Ich denke, Sie
wissen, dass ich das denke  Es gibt viele
gute Republikaner, denen die
Wahl in Integrität am Herzen liegt und die verstehen,
dass
Sie wissen, dass diese Fehlinformationen und
Desinformationen das System untergraben werden.
Ich weiß also, dass es
republikanische Stimmen gibt, die da draußen
sagen: „Schaut auf euch.“  Wissen Sie, wir haben ein großartiges
Wahlsystem, wissen Sie, nicht wahr? Seien
Sie nicht da draußen und verbreiten Sie
Fehlinformationen aus politischen
Gründen, ähm, aber ja, ich glaube,
es gibt Grund zur
Sorge
So dunkel es jetzt auch ist, IA,
es wird nicht das ganze Jahr über so sein, also wird die Sonne
herauskommen, das ist die gute [
Musik]
-Nachricht.
Kapitalversand, vielen Dank
[Musik]
Anna